hi everyone my name is Debra chamber her
brother to the jammers and this is
Tamara's never seen with Taylor
today we're watching Fear and Loathing
in Las Vegas I've seen the cover of this
movie lots of times in DVD rental stores
but I've never watched it yeah that one
I know it's about two people in Las
Vegas on a lot of drugs I didn't know is
with Johnny Depp oh really
and it's the actor from last Jedi how I
know him I is pretty pumped about it
yeah you're right Doug Walker has said
that he enjoyed it the first time but it
took him a few times to like really
loved it now it's one of his favorite
movies so cool I'm excited to see like
one of his favorite movies but I'm also
like oh is it gonna be the same or like
the first time I see it I'm gonna be
like ah wait okay all right let's get
into it
1 2 3
[Music]
you
what what what I truly do not know what
to think about this movie but what
happened what just happened the
cinematography sequences of him on acid
was they were just so awesome especially
the one with all the dinosaurs when they
first arrived well yeah that dinosaur
scene was really cool that was awesome
forgot about well cuz so much happen
yeah there's a lot that doesn't make
sense so by the end it's just like a
whole lot of jigsaw puzzle pieces
there's so many specifically funny
points that I was like all I got to talk
about that when we're speaking about it
in the reaction but at this point I it's
gone nothing none of them like connect
in any way it was like halfway through
and you're like I think still waiting
for a storyline German when we finally
realized there wasn't ever gonna be a
storyline and after they got done with
the desert bike section it's like what
well when he starts when Johnny Depp's
character starts leaving Vegas and then
he gets a call from his attorney who's
like you should be in Vegas so then he
goes back in the is room he's in Vegas
yeah at that point it's like oh so
there's just no story here we're just in
a drug-induced yeah like this happened
cool the movies in the in the fiction
category
yeah and it's loosely based off of
truths that are in a book I'm probably
getting a lot of this wrong but it's
it's fiction but it's loosely based off
of things that did happen on two
specific trips that he took in the 70s
with his attorney to Vegas under a lot
of drugs and a lot of alcohol
okay the briefcase scenery list stuff
like the grocery list
different substances all the drugs in
all of the alcohol that he has yes
that's fun cuz it's like what are you
getting and it's like okay so this is
gonna be this is what we got going on so
we know what we're in for
right right well and at that point it
still seems like there was gonna be some
sort of storyline well cuz it's just set
up at that point they're driving through
the desert it's like two friends
literally two friends drive through the
desert just a car and a briefcase full
of drugs Toby the Klan tobey maguire
also spider-man is like okay what a fun
buddy cop right he what's going on here
yeah and then it just literally starts
making no sense after that it starts
like doing like multiple timelines stuff
and then you like jump back to Tobey
Maguire's like oh yeah that's right word
Tobey Maguire in the car in the desert
yeah and then which is great you forget
about Tobey Maguire for a second why
there's a lot of things that were really
funny like the artist who only does
Barbara Streisand portraits hilarious
Lucy also what happens in her voice I
was with Lucy why did they break up and
like he loves her and then like she they
see her and she doesn't what is
happening why it isn't certainly have so
many lethal weapons on him at all times
yeah what's up the best so like he has a
gun and he's like I'm gonna kill someone
in the next hour if I don't get out of
here it's like well don't have a gun
that's the first problem the only word
that made me laugh out loud is I think
we were saying in our opinion the best
scene of the movie in North Vegas where
they go to the diner and he asks how
much the pie is and he's just like
threatened her life and his poor
waitress he's like having a like a
mental trauma breakdown
and he's just like disgusting and sweaty
at a table ain't forty pounds for the
role yeah he said he gained 40 pounds by
eating doughnuts same he's there and
he's like how much for the pie and he
has the pie in his hand he's behind the
counter and it just looks like he's
winding up its Piper yeah she's like 40
cents per slice he's like okay just take
this and that was hilarious Johnny Depp
it was really good in this I think when
he had his hat on he looked just like
Walter like identical to Walter he did a
really good job especially specifically
his acid trip in the very beginning when
he's getting into the hotel I think
that's really good portrays being high
very well and I'm always amazed at that
same with being drunk I think it's
pretty hard to portray that when you're
stone-cold sober so whether he was or
not he did a really good job once they
went to the desert and he's like oh I'm
trying to get these bikes I'm trying to
record these bikes I'm trying to drink
this beer as like what's going on and
then after that I just completely lost
has lost it yeah yeah I even done this
in a long time but I asked for
predictions from people to see mainly
just get a gauge on what people think
we're gonna see the Eric buss on to it
Vic says he's the Star Wars guy he says
you'll say what the at least eight times
yes Eric
yes also everyone should go follow Eric
he's awesome
I we the whole time like every three
minutes we looked at each other like
you'll feel like the entire movie is
taken completely out of context as if
you've just walked in on the weirdest
part of a conversation
that is Oh Jordan after this is all said
and done you should read the book hunter
s Thompson was one of a kind I can see
that yes I was saying while we were
watching it how could this be a book
right just is it just like a page of but
like a story and then it goes on to a
next page of a story like because
there's no story
incoherent like imagery and you'll be
surprised by some of the cameos in this
movie yeah
there were so many people popping up
that we were like oh that's that one
person Cameron Diaz look damn girl
can get it in his movies and all the
time she's so fine it was in a random
elevator seat like so weirdly utilized
yeah but she ruled in it and there were
so many cameos like up there so many
times were like oh it's that one guy
thing that one thing random so raised I
got one midget that looks like
Christopher Walken we both thought that
it was Christopher Walken it's like
during the bathtub scene you'll be all
WTF I'd be not specifically just a
bathroom scene but but definitely during
the bathtub scene yet how this guy's
have an attorney yeah I don't know I
don't know about the legitimacy of his
attorneys - how many other clients does
this guy have is it just him because if
it's just hunter s Thompson that makes
sense but if he had other clients they
should find representation elsewhere
you'll swear off drugs forever
next you'll want to watch this one with
a big ol glass of wine plus you'll be
swatting at invisible bats for a while
so okay I love that he's swatting at the
invisible bats but then there's an
actual bat as roadkill was that
something that was already there were
they hinting that there were bats what
was the most the symbolism of there
being an actual dead
there are a lot of moments where I was
like what is real what does I feel like
multiple timelines shit going on half
the time yeah yeah well also all that
stuff with the things outside of Vegas
like when he was in that bathroom and
the the LSD you got on his sleeve and
that was well yeah I guess that kind of
licking his sleeve sure and like who's
the guy and it was like what look at
what what are you doing you will wonder
if it's accurate to real-life drug use
you will at least be impressed by the
visuals oh yeah yeah they were really
really really impressive and cool and
kept my attention which is so weird
because usually the non-story movies
like this to be quite honest they kind
of whore me this at least kept my
attention so the visuals were a giant
part of that you'll feel like you need
to be in rehab by the end they certainly
need rehab sure yeah man
is it weird though that I kind of found
him sexy a little bit his you may not
know what you just saw but you're
probably gonna like it yeah I would
agree yeah the general consensus is that
hey you're not supposed to really
understand that I'm yeah expected that
life you're not gonna get it if there's
a lot of cameras never seen episodes
that I like don't understand but like
something I should have understood and
everyone in the comments are like you
idiot you stupid simple day
[Applause]
ladies it's like not like everyone's
super gets it I enjoyed it I am confused
by it and I definitely recognize that
it's something I need to see more than
once but I enjoyed it I wish that I had
a passion in life that was as specific
as painting only barbra streisand
portrait yeah to find that fire thank
you so much for watching this very weird
experience for Taylor and I I will see
you next week
Mac okay let's do some an ash I wish I
had blonde long hair
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you